quarta laggiù è nuovo perché succede si
è bagnato
[Musica]
come potete vedere dai nostri ospiti
dalle nostre magliette così torniamo
inclusione a grandissima richiesta
tornano gli stipendi in prigioni infatti
la più forte team room superato i 10mila
mi piace woman roma l'accordo è un altro
step room in prigione che anche questi
groom raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace ce ne
sarà un'altra impresa i cani sices
poliziotto mettetevi comodi privi di
bourne e iniziamo per talento le altre
eccoci qua come potete vedere dobbiamo
entrare in questo caso io adoro i
cartelli ormai lo sapete ma non c'è
quesito cosa è un personaggio appena
detto umano dal cielo sono uguali sono
altri alcuni parlano però va beh noi
entriamo nel cervello
ora ho visto che esterno che bene
chi vuol dire che ci sono ogni ha detto
aiutaci umano è successo qualcosa di
brutto conosciuto mostafa questi serini
non savini lo saprete già una trappola
quante corse l'era vita sbagliati stiamo
bene con veroli che si sfracella
frazionamento numero ci vuole contare
quanti sfracella menti avrà vitale
burrone attento al lancio giusto in
tempo
io abbiamo superato la prima parte è
solo tiene perfettamente di un'italia
torino preparano la corda per barare per
karina invece spalline con le palle di
fango
non ci credo che vieta le mie parate o
tratta succedendo
i rovi dell acqua forse il nome del
cattivo queste note in italiano il
forgiatore viveva quale forgiatore di
spade forza oggi una katana tutto perché
si muovono ho preso fuoco
terzo braccio e la mente cosa ma
entrando dentro una sorta di castello un
po ed i giapponesi che con questo fu
bozzetto ha detto tiro era un
leggendario ma adesso non c'è più che
vuol dire che sono andato patrimoni le
testate e secondo me il mio può salvare
questi animaletti super carini accetta
senza che ce ne esce esserci solo
verbale giganti che cascano stai attento
anche se mi piacerebbe vedere e pensare
che si è detto fare aiuto
sta volando come speculando è no ma
perché succede se bancato no ho visto
più rinascere la casa in continuazione
la giornata nel mondo aiuto mano
faurisson baciato mister e sono qui
davanti guarda io ti vedo non ci credo
se ne può fare senza farti ma per torre
celare fatti controlli forse ce l'ho
fatta brava ok adesso dobbiamo alzare
contento è un po distrutto che vedo
questo arresto giapponese le anime sono
inquiete le anime di che i fantasmi che
con i quasi nodo dei fantasmi
adoro sono tipo i fantasmi di chi
abitava il castello probabilmente poi
c'è un cavaliere ci sono il regime anche
[Musica]
non vedo l'ora di scoprire se correnti
di questo cartello dovremo passare al ce
ne sono forse è vero non provo ma questo
verso ok
riproviamo tutto comincia qui stesso per
favorire la dama che balla comunque
adoro troppo ovviamente alla fine delle
fibre scrive tesi che voto gli va da 1 a
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok ho un'idea di scoprire tutta la
storia di questo castello e con l'altro
esterino degli umani vecchi se non ci
sono più successo
[Musica]
che cosa può dire piuttosto dobbiamo
salire la sopra questo è il vecchio
villaggio poco a loro mi ricorda un
fatto in migliasso fate questo periodo
sono sempre maggiore eco socializzazione
fatto c'è qualcosa di inquietante
raggiungere un robot gigante con un
ragno aiuto non voglio andare da quella
parte
e io ho trovato il passaggio con solidi
e poi bisogna fare bisogna salire i
quali tutto minimi di corsa piano piano
senza cadere ma sono abbastanza rifare
tutto non a caso lo stesso nella campana
o no la campagna verso la porta verso
quel robot brano i nostri pc guardiani
proteggono ancora il castello o per
fortuna se qualcuno che protegge il
castello ma saranno questi mostri
[Musica]
veramente inquietanti stanno puntando
dei laser qua nel ponte vuoi evitare
questi laser sicuramente o che il piano
piano si è appreso non è solo tipo delle
spie del castello che non vogliono che
entriamo
[Musica]
38 d'italia
poi non ci credo ce l'ho fatto e di
nuovo capo dove mordiamo cosa sia adesso
dice di accendere il fuoco
accendiamo di tutti
ok sto prendo il cancello ci sono altri
guardiani aspettiamo cosa dicono questi
personaggi sono passati tanti anni molti
quartieri stanno dormendo per fortuna è
accaduto ormai la porta non si apre
quindi guarda ci sono molti i guardiani
militare sfracellato subito questi si
muovono
proviamo io no no nel rimorso il laser è
possibile che i traumi ma è così 4 che
stiamo andando letto c'è un portale la
gestione teschio la stanza principale
davanti a te ed è piena di oscurità dopo
le porte andiamo piani vivo attento non
cadere si sono fatta mandare il
passaggio o no è come forse troppo sopra
si sindaco solo perché mi stava altre
sulla torta si chiama un massimo per
forza dobbiamo sentire questo processo
attenta e difficile un trenino che ci
aspetta dai siti diversi
[Musica]
che bello giro panoramico adoro queste 0
fa non ho mica di questo club perché sta
portando la torre fino ad ora del multi
900 queste creature fanno il verso degli
atti nomi dove c'è scritto che sia un
entrata segreta sto fra il mulino a
vento
ok andiamo sopra sempre entrare da sotto
salire sopra a segrete segreto di stato
queste avventure quando sono così grandi
l'escape room
adoro troppo 600 in cima o sali riguarda
abitativo romanzo che dobbiamo aspettare
dove dobbiamo fare adesso forse vita
sottomarina ciarimboli detto non sono
caduto dopo giu anche io sono
cristallizzati stay ma perchè vi pare la
fa per saperlo nel vuoto mi sono buttata
nella torre ma perché nella prigione
nelle segrete sono aggiuntivi perché non
voglio fare sesso ma qualcosa se le
prigioni con le sbarre di teschi eccoci
qua finalmente vita legge la pasta dopo
mezz'ora si è sfracellato 25.000 volte
finalmente eccolo qua siamo pronti a
fare ma l'ha preso
no non ci credo mi danno non è stato
accettato
non ci credo è stato più volte ok sto
arrivando l'attenzione qui altri tipo
dei pendoli ma non vedi che sono delle
asce sapendo che ci credono progettati
mai wow il prossimo solo che vedranno 6
draghi solo dopo ma io adoro troppo
perché si è fatta benissimo poi che col
d'eze questo poi passarlo così wow ma
che bella questa prigione sono
dell'aliena di un'anfora dentro se
qualche sfortunato sì che predomina
turato ho detto l'ultimo lire l'ultimo
anello si rompe saranno il primo una
trappola
il penultimo brano rotto mentre lo so io
sono caduto e allora perché il caso
avuto porta dice questi umani erano i
nostri amici mi aiuta non voglio
rimanere chiude questa prigione ma ecco
dobbiamo andare laggiù lo conoscete quel
personaggio non vi dico che personaggio
è comunque un pensiero
è un personaggio famoso che io adoro
tantissimo scrivetemi nei commenti stelo
conoscete di che film è molto
inquietante in tempo a vederlo perché mi
sono state celate questo schifo come un
po un'ispirazione il film di miyazaki
che io amo
voglio che solo personaggio l'aqua parla
con i nostri amici
uno di loro alla la chiave ok parliamo
con tutti chi sono e mappe ranieri una
chiave non sono io chiedi a barry
bastano ancora vivi anche se sono degli
scheletri di questi sono degli scheletri
di sé una chiave ma glielo abbiamo già
chiesto ha detto no ma premi fosse
bisogno di prendere in giro perché
abbiamo o no no c'era una ti sei buttato
vero più un altro aggiungo che hai fatto
a chiedere a lui dobbiamo seguire la
chiave
avremo una chiara del suo nome era non
l'ho potuto commettere quel nome
brian non lo so è un altro abbiamo
chiesto a tutti non ce n'è un altro che
guarda solo porta verso aperta
hai preso la prima verso gli uomini come
vediamo perché vorrei in qualcosa mi
dice che non è ancora finita
dov'è la poi tutto dritti dallo chef
romano dal caffè i motori g g robotici
una controllando i corridoi per vedere
se sta scappando qualcuno mi ha preso
con il laser o no
non manca il monte
se preso che tu stai riuscito a capire
se solo teatro la terra centra però mi
sono nascosta così nomi bene continuare
così ok mi nascondo qua adesso di ponte
ok ciò che sono più ampi
ok prima punta ho sbagliato
dove sei andato eccoti nuovi compiti non
lo si fa di far venire adesso
che brutti questi mostri se avete fatto
sta che dovrebbe cercare di qua aspetta
sbrigati brigati che sta arrivando
ok dai sono proprio qui dietro vero è
che ce l'ha fatta quando subito però
dice ci stiamo avvicinando ma stai
attento umano che dobbiamo quel botto e
quindi e questo è niente qualcosa mi
dice che sono delle note meglio evitarle
ok salviamo attento ci sono i guardiani
che ci sono questi che qua con
coordinare spino inseguono attento tetto
non bastare sui buchi ok
sembra che poi inchiostro si muovono
perfetto non è facile e sono scappata è
riuscito ad avere vantare tra noi ce
l'abbiamo fatta senza essere prese
comunque ad ora questa ambientazione di
questo castello è usato parente
concretizzare ma non bisogna saltare
sulla fiat riforma federalista che
dobbiamo salire sopra quella ruota
vediamo ok saliamo ok io sono passato
dall'altra parte tu dove sei finito
schiacciato dalla ruota di al sic arco
vabbè mentre evitare continui a
spiaccicare si è badato esplorare qua
queste casette sia prima ma ho preso una
ruota dove se non so cosa mi servirà
voglio aprire queste parole
perché non fanno aprirlo più bello che
si fosse per superare queste carte c'è
un altro bambole ma il bug che non sei
altro
c'è un ponte con un personaggio ok
arrivo da prima controllare se
qualcos'altro quasi niente
ac alla chiave del font lui videcamera
vicino se la ruota è la chiave di ci
vediamo brevemente sono gatti e volpi
che sono arrivati da questo portale
ombre di un altro mondo non so se voglio
sapere che cosa c'è nel profeta portale
punto neanche se devo entrare qua devo
salire la sopra vediamo
ok nel portale non entra ma è così ok
proviamo a salire qua sopra che ci siamo
uguali comunque dormo dell'ora
riscoprire il segreto finale di questo
schifo ha tra l'altro non ci chiedete
sempre questo ai nomi delle pietre un
quali sono non siamo trovarli un mi
dimentico sempre ti aspetta il portale
per uscire dall escape from fa un
contratto tipo ok allora saltiamo
quaggiù ha comunque è stato richiamo
cercherà di ricordarmi di dire che il
nome sempre comunque il nome di questa è
a khartum in the sky che vuol dire un
secondo nel cielo preferite in inglese
quindi mi raccomando tutti veltroni
l'inglese
ecco lo dice l ok andiamo a letto con
cipe si schermiva paese dove davvero le
cose vediamo che posiziona questo
personaggio
la chiave qui sono sicuro dimmi dove
cosa mi dice che questo poi vi metto
crollerà mi sembra proprio una trappola
questa vado io da velato attiviamo
controllato che ci ha provato a testa
non ci credo mentre stavo sono chiave
sotto potevo farne i buttati perché
riusciamo ad essere quasi una porta mi
chiamo non avresti mai trovato la chiave
senza della vela mercato aperto wow
stiamo nei sotterranei del castello
questi gli ingranaggi
no il fuoco è un po difficile prendere
la mira
ok ci sono dopo un pastore si sono anche
i buchi in questi granati uffa prossimo
dai ne mancano solo uno
io non ci credo l'ho fatta e adesso sul
quale ingranaggio devo saltare il
prossimo pronta requa lavorando nel
frattempo vediamo se qua un ascensore da
idee ancora ingranaggi e sono riusciti
ad arrivare massimo proprio massimo
impegnandomi al secondo tempo riesca
ascolese allarme sempre questo settore
dai facciamo tutti il tifo per vi basti
vita né vita né allora nel frattempo
esploro quel castello l'ascensore mi ha
portato qua sopra dai vitale sta
continuando talenti ma poi ce la farà
vediamo c'è scritto il pericolo c'è del
pericolo fa davanti ma noi siamo con te
umano dai sbrigati vitale così non dovrò
affrontare da solo questo per il
centenario
ho come l'impressione che ci sia attivo
un nemico finale davvero pericolo dice
un teschio e come capita raramente dopo
altri 10 mila strozzamenti allora che
cosa dovremmo fare adesso
lo chiede come sto chiave ridendo o che
sia persa la porta perché stava ridendo
forse siamo caduti in una trappola
guarda c'è una pedana magica impegno
cosa dicono
prendi questa spada ti salverà dal
dall'oscurità ok ma ieri
o malate adesso stiamo chiedendo lo
spirito al penso che dobbiamo affrontare
questo dramma nova bella toro braccia in
atto sì sì lupo bella piaciuto un fitto
allen ce n'è ancora troppo facile
attento sono due arti sono juventino
essere simile così via che la mia via
via vai bene allora uno si ok io abbiamo
scoperto una provincia non trovano altro
spettata aspetto a questa piaciuto feb
ma a me sembra che stia combattendo da
solo dopo c'era anche quello finale per
vito mi aspettavo questa volta devono
aspettare questo attento come sappiamo
che ce l'abbiamo fatta ma anche quello
finale sei pronto sto combattendo il
mondo l'ultimo di questi 3 ok io però la
vitalità che sta a sentire io ho
pochissima vita mia rosso queste ci sono
le aiuto c'è un asse gigante forse c'è
una passione non ci credo che ce l'ho
fatta stavo per morire subito fatta
salva ha proseguito c'è anche la musica
3 un parte della mia piatta invece
battendola combattendo da solo non lo
sto perfetta passando dai puoi farcela
dopo troppo divertente veloci e provoca
figurò battaglia finale vediamo cosa si
dicono i nostri amici piccoli di ce
l'hai fatta sei salvato dal re delle
ombre
adoro e ora questo siamo liberi perché
lo sapete su questo ascensore altre
istituzionale largo che ti mando salire
abbiamo preso intensi abbiamo un po ma
vediamo che merita un 10 perché mi piace
è stata bellissima
poiché a vuoto di dare è ora vi lasciamo
parma 4 milioni anche carmelo dei nostri
altri video in casa scuola che preferite
buona visione ciao